I have been telling you about the
Orwellian Newspeak that has been scaling
up from Trump and the administration
lately they're making claims that aren't
just inaccurate but the are they're the
exact opposite of reality in many cases
and I've said it before and I'll say it
again this is a strategy and this is a
strategy to make people question whether
they can believe anything that they hear
at all and we've talked about the
dynamics of how that works before if
Trump says I don't know pick a topic
stormy Daniels I don't know who she is I
met her we didn't pay anything we paid
but it was Cohen's money but I didn't
pay him back but I did pay him back all
of a sudden it becomes sort of like a
non-issue in the mind of Trumpets
because they've heard every possible
side of that issue espoused by Donald
Trump at least at some point they don't
know what to believe they'll go back to
seeing the Red Sox Yankee game instead
and then not worry anymore about what
actually is the truth about stormy
Daniels Trump is now using this strategy
on Trump Russia he is now claiming that
he's worried that Russia will meddle in
the 2018 midterms to help Democrats this
is straight-up concern trolling check
out Trump's tweet from yesterday where
he said quote I'm very concerned that
Russia will be fighting very hard to
have an impact on the upcoming election
yeah okay well that part's true and he
goes on to say based on the fact that no
president has been tougher on Russia
than me they will be pushing very hard
for the Democrats they definitely don't
want Trump now of course none of that is
true there's no evidence that Russia is
trying to help Democrats Trump certainly
hasn't been the toughest president on
Russia and all the evidence is that
Russia does want Trump now I do want to
say okay before we get on to like the
bulk of the analysis Russia's goals are
broader than Trump per se so Trump is a
means to an end he makes the u.s. look
terrible he makes Putin look better and
stronger in comparison he destabilizes
American democracy and makes people
question whether our democratic system
is even working it's possible that
Russia would help Democrats like if
Russia determined that that would be the
next thing like if Russia determined
that okay Trump we help Trump win and
and things are crazy let's now create
even more chaos by helping Democrats
achieve a majority and a house senator
both because of how it will further
unhinge Trump that is how Russia thinks
there's just no evidence that that's
actually going on right now oh yeah I
mean it's pretty clear that in 2012 they
favored Barack Obama over Mitt Romney
right but in 2016 what do you mean by
that well Romney was pretty tough on
Russia and oh they liked Obama more fair
enough but in the recent Helsinki summit
Putin said that he wanted Trump to win
right because that would normally is
normalized relations between the US and
Russia so this is gaslighting that's
ultimately what it is this is another
example of projection it's Orwellian
Newspeak where everything is the
opposite and this is now something that
someone is feeding Donald Trump I
actually don't think that Trump is
coming up with this himself anymore I
think that somebody is feeding to Trump
take the line that Russia wants the Dems
to win and this is also another de facto
attack on American intelligence by the
way Trump's not saying it in his tweet
and Trump's tweet he just says Russia
wants the Dems but we know that the
consensus of the intelligence community
is that Russia metal to help Trump when
Trump says the opposite when Trump says
I've been super tough on Russia and
Russia wants the Dems that's sort of a
de facto way of Trump saying he doesn't
believe the intelligence community and
this is monstrous dangerous gaslighting
and it's only dangerous because people
will believe it and will be tricked by
it period if we had a voting public
overall that saw this and said that's
not true we know what the truth is and
this isn't it it wouldn't be so
dangerous but it's dangerous because
there are a lot of people out there who
are gonna believe this stuff and if we
needed more proof that Trump isn't
really worried about Russia hacking the
Democrats hacking to help Democrats
rather it's that he's doing nothing
about it right think about this for a
second if your Trump or if you're a
Republican and you want Republicans to
win and you think Russia is helping
Democrats you would immediately try to
stop Russian meddling Trump hasn't tried
to stop Russian meddling and in fact he
said just last week how strong and tough
Putin was in his denials that meddling
even took place and additionally
Republicans just blocked a bid to a bill
rather to extend a
election security grants if you run the
House and Senate and you think Russia's
helping the Democrats why would you
block funding for election security you
would say hey we need to stop it because
Russia wants the Dems none of them
believe that that's what's going on or
those additional sanctioned over
positions overwhelmingly passed by
Congress that Trump for the longest time
refused to implement it was today in
trying to implement them it's not insane
to say we can imagine why Russia might
want Democrats to win over Republicans
we could we could imagine that
circumstance but there's no evidence
that that's going on it goes completely
counter to what our intelligence
agencies are saying and three if anybody
believes that that's what Russia's doing
they're doing nothing to try to prevent
it which is what makes it abundantly
clear that this is a show it's a gong
show it's a joke and more importantly
it's working I was trolling some of the
not actually I wasn't posting anything
but I was sort of browsing some of the
known internet enclaves of the most
committed Trumpets and they are they are
now saying Russia wants the Democrats
Russia wants the Democrats to win and we
need to vote in November because
otherwise Russia and the Dems will take
the House and Senate so it's working any
harebrained notion that is presented by
Trump is now being taken as gospel by
trumpet and that's why this stuff is so
abundantly dangerous